herzlich willkommen zum Telekolleg in Würde
altern muss man jetzt dazu sagen der Kollege
Wischmann und ich sind ja selber schon in
dieser sagen wir mal leicht abgehangenen
Lebensphase wo man sich bei jedem neuen
Paar Schuhe unwillkürlich fragt lohnt sich
das eigentlich noch ja gut häufiger als ich es
klar meine er ist ja Geburtsjahrgang 1937 aber
hört man ihn klagen nein ne ich finde das ganz
toll er macht viele Sachen noch alleine findet
alleine vom Lokus zurück super super und er macht
das in würde und er steht dazu und das macht ihn
ja zu einer einmaligen Erscheinung in diesem Land
denn ich weiß nicht ob ihnen das auch aufgefallen
ist in Deutschland will ja partout keiner mehr als
sein keiner will mehr alt sein früher da kannten
alte Menschen noch ihren Platz im Leben Omas
hat einen Kittel an und Opas hat einen Hüter
auf die meistens ein Tick zu klein waren und
beide hatten immer Erfrischungstücher dabei
und heute statt im Fallen Licht von Sat.1 Gold
vor sich hin zu verwesen wie ist die Natur für
sie vorgesehen hat besetzen die Mumien den
ganzen Tag die guten Geräte im Fitnessstudio
weibliche Gesichts Rosinen bitte du ich habe
es aufgeschrieben es lese ich sofort das stimmt
weibliche gesichtsrosinen färben sich den
grauen Mob hellrot oder noch schlimmer Aubergine
inklusive modischer Totalschäden im öffentlichen
Raum die ganz leicht zu vermeiden werden ich
erinnere hier mal schnell an drei einfache
Grundregeln bevor der textilfrühling über
uns alle hereinbricht erstens schon mit
Beginn der Pubertät wird die öffentlich
getragene kurze Hose beim Mann zum Tabu mit
über 30 zum Ärgernis und ab 60 zur Freakshow
ein Betroffener Klatsch kein Mensch will die sehen
diese teakholzfarbenen Ötzi Stelzen grauenvoll
zweitens es gibt in Deutschland kein Gesetz weil
sie das gedacht haben es gibt kein Gesetz das
Rentner verpflichtet ab 3 Grad plus mit
sogenannten Trekking Sandalen durch die
Gegend zu rennen ohne Socken bei jedem Schritt
fallen 10 Gramm Hautschuppen auf dem Bürgersteig
so und drittens noch ein ganz wichtiger
Hinweis für männliche Senioren das Masse
Shirt heißt nicht zufällig so
ja einfach mal drüber nachdenken
sonst sonst hieß es ja labberarme Hemd
oder so ähnlich ne der ganze Freizeit
Look macht keinen Sinn für Leute die
immer Freizeit haben verstehen Sie
Freunde um was die Freizeitgestaltung angeht
kann natürlich bin Deutschland jeder machen was
er will sag mal wenn das jetzt ein bestimmten
Frauentyp hilft sich in der Volkshochschule
durch die Wechseljahre zu trommeln warum nicht ne
muss ja nicht mir gefallen ne nur beim Thema Sex
da ist für mich wirklich Ende alte Menschen reden
nicht über Sex Feierabend meine Großeltern hatten
zwei Kinder weil sie sich genau zweimal im Bett
unglücklich umgedreht haben meine Damen und Herren
ja heute gibt es ü70 Swingerclubs
man sieht in der U-Bahn reizende
ältere Damen die Fifty Shades of grey Lesen der
ganze SM Quatsch ist plötzlich total angesagt nur
natürlich auch sehr deutsche Art also versaut und
verklemmt zugleich kriegen wirklich nur wir hin
ja die gleichen Leute die sonst den Nachbarn
anzeigen wenn die Biotonne 3 cm zu weit links
steht sind jetzt auf einmal total verrucht und
lassen sich von ihrer Eulen den großen Brocken
den 32 bending ja sonst macht er keinen
Spaß du Dödel ja lieber die Daten CD an dir
jetzt hast du mehr über
dich Verrat als du wolltest
[Applaus]
wenn auch Sie sich emotional berührt fühlen
in dem was wir hier machen gibt es wie in
jeder unserer Flamingo Chance auch die
Gelegenheit für Sie als Publikum direkt
in das laufende Programm einzugreifen ein
Feedback zu geben per Twitter denn auch
wenn wir heute abend drüber lästern wie
sich manche an Jugendkultur ran Wanzen
müssen wir uns natürlich trotzdem
an die Jugendkultur rein wandern
reicht uns auch schon der erste Tweet wer
schreibt denn Nashorn Muschi 69 schreibt uns
ich finde Wischmeyer echt toll heute Abend
aber was ist denn bitte mit dem Pila war los
[Applaus]
früher fand ich den mal lustig aber seid
ihr so fett geworden ist kann ich nicht
mehr drüber lachen Olli das musste dann einfach
mal so annehmen würde ich sagen nee ist klar du
Dietmar wenn Nashorn Muschi das schreibt
nehme ich mir das natürlich voll zu Herzen
können wir einfach weitermachen so eine scheiße
ich weiß echt nicht was dieser pampige Unterton
jetzt soll wenn einer Zuschauerin ich nehme
an das eine Zuschauerin wenn der aufgefallen
ist dass einer von uns lustig ist und der
einzige der andere einfach nur Fett dann
kann man das doch einfach mal so stehen lassen
ja gut jetzt Mensch blöde Nashorn [__] bitte
können Sie auch mal wenn Sie Ihre Familie
überraschen wollen beim Scrabble einsetzen
weißt du weißt du dass man in Hannover den
Getränke Rückgabeautomaten Nashorn [__] nennt
weißt du total scheiße
du ich hätte das Geräusch dazu gar nicht gebraucht
um den Geld zu verstehen muss ehrlich sagen wusste
nicht dass seine Fantasie auch dreckig ist
natürlich noch besser beim Scrabble wenn sie
sich das Aufschreiben wollen mann oh mann oh mann
oh Mann noch viel schlimmer finde ich allerdings
die Leute die ihre Jugend die sie ja für die
prägende Zeit ihres Lebens halten also zwischen
14 und 18 bis weit ins Kreisen Alter fortführen
wollen und überhaupt sich nie entwickelt haben
als Erwachsener die stehen dann z.B als mit
ganzkörper Jeans Bekleidung von den Open
airbühnen des Sommers die Haare sind immer noch
lang jedoch ergraut und etwas zu akkurat gekämpft
oben Spiel zum Beispiel Genesis oder Jethro
Tal oder scheißegal manchmal wackeln sie mit
dem Fuß manchmal mit dem Kopf wenn einer fragt
ob sie noch ein Bier holen ich muss noch fahren
die retro-jugend amüsiert sich gerade wenn die
alten Bands wieder über Land ziehen sich die
Generation vor dem Pillenknick in ihre
Pubertät zurück zwei Stunden wie leblos
vor großen Bühnen stehen vielleicht
ein letztes Mal die Helden von früher
sehen die mal damals als sie noch wichtig
waren nur vom kassettenrekorde erkannte
stämmige Hausfrauen wackeln noch einmal so mit
dem Hintern wie vor 30 Jahren im Jugendheim
man nimmt es ihnen sogar ab dass sie Phil Collins
Musik irgendwie berührt oder dass sie Mick Jagger
für ein erotischen Mann halten doch man möchte
nicht dabei zuschauen wenn sie es zeigen
Retro Jugend Männer fahren motorradschrauben an
Oldtimern rum oder saufen Bier also richtiges Bier
sie gucken alte Filme mit vielen Hubschraubern
oder mit Bruce Willis abends und am Wochenende
haben sie die Schnauze voll von der digitalen
Scheißwelt in der sie heute leben müssen dann
muss es wieder nach Benzin riechen die Musik
muss aus der Gitarre schreiben ehrlich ist
das Zauberwort für alles was damals gut war die
Rockmusik die Motoren die Typen und die Frauen
die waren auch viel besser und das Vögeln
öfter aber nicht so umständlich die Zeit
ist drüber hinweggegangen die Kassettenrekorder
Menschen sind alt geworden manchmal aber kommt
wieder eine Band in die Stadt deren
Namen man früher mit Kugelschreiber
auf die Federmappe gekritzelt hat nachdem das
erste Erstaunen vorüber ist was die leben noch
dann kauft man sich die Eintrittskarten
Kalle und Doris kommen auch mit das passt
ja gehen wir danach noch auf den Rotwein
du sag mal Schatz denkst du bitte an die
Schaumstoffkissen diese zusammenklappbaren
Schatz wie was nur Stehplätze und
ja Pech es gibt immer noch Rockkonzerte
die nicht komplett bestuhlt werden auch
die toilettensituation ist very old bestuhl sprich
Dixi Scheißhäuser dafür dauert der Retro Rock auch
nur eine Stunde man kann danach noch zum Italiener
wenn mit dem Einbruch der Tagesthemen das Konzert
vorüber ist gehen der ganzkörper-anzug und das
völlige Mädchen zu ihrem Mittelklasse Limousine
und beide denken wie schön dass wir so dicht
geparkt haben und mit dem Gedanken ist das gute
Gefühl noch mal jung zu sein auch schon wieder
verflogen oh traurig so eine traurige Geschichte
traurige Geschichte ach nee du weißt was ich
persönlich ja noch viel nerviger finde als den
ganzkörper-jeans Anzug hast du glaube ich genannt
ja das sind die ganzkörper Jeans Anzüge die auch
noch so feiern wie damals also die auch bei ihren
Partys sich immer noch wie 16-Jährige Verhalten
Fete sagte man dauert glaube ich genau da traf
man sich mit seiner Clique ja mir das als wir
noch Freunde hatten ja das ist Gott sei Dank
vorbei ja der Mensch wird ja auch zwar steht
älter aber seine Vorstellung von einem
geilen Party die fahren immer noch der Stufe
eines 16-jährigen so feiert noch der arrivierte
Marketing Mensch seinen Eintritt ins greisen Alter
mit einer Sause aus dem Mofa zeigt alkoholsatz
Nudelsalat bringt jeder mit und in einer Ecke
des Reihenhaus Kellers steht die Anlage und brüllt
alte Statiken durchgemacht haben als wir alle noch
jung und gierig waren reichten diese Intelligenzen
für eine schweinegeile Party bei der was hängen
blieb mindestens ein mörderischer Kater wenn nicht
ein Rudel frischer Sackratten im Feuchtbiotop
denn zwei Dinge waren es die uns damals
aus dem Hause trieben die Delirium durch
Verabfolgung umsonst ein Alkohols und oder
flachlegung eine scharfen Gerätes wobei
ersteres immer gelang weiteres fast nie
aber als versprechen steht Präsident war
heute kann ein Rudel 40-jähriger mit dem Dreisatz
fressen Alk und lauter Rockmusik nicht mal mehr
den eigenen Schweinehund hinter der inneren
Zentralheizung hervorlocken gefressen wird
eh zu viel Alke zieht da vor der Glotze und
Menschen ab 40 die in Reihenhäusern zur suzi
Quatro tanzen sind ja lächerlich was überhaupt
sicher fehlt ist der Anreiz sich diese Tortur
aus Alkoholvergiftung und zugedröhne überhaupt
anzutun es ist ja die Aussicht auf sexuelle Beute
die bei einem Pärchen Auftrieb des Mittelalters
gänzlich abhanden gekommen ist da stehen sie dann
lustlos in der Gegend rum nagen an Hühner Beinen
nimmt man alkoholfreien Getränken und schielen
ständig auf den Breitling Chrono wann ist denn
nun endlich 11 Uhr wird um halbwegs anständig
den Abgang zu machen zu Hause den Spätfilm
gucken mit Carola im Benz Möbel kuscheln und
am anderen Morgen ganz allein die FAZ auf
dem Scheiß auslesen das ist die Utopia 40
wenn der Sexualtrieb seine letzte Ruhestätte
gefunden hat muss man sich nicht mehr die
Nächte um die Ohren schlagen warum aber
feiern immer noch längst der graute so
als sei es gerade gestern gewesen
da sie die Mofa am Jugendzentrum
abgestellt haben er diese überlebte Form
pubertärer Geselligkeit in ihrer ganzen
peinlichen Größe man erleben möchte dem
empfehle ich eine Party bei den Grünen
was hast du denn entschuldige mal hol dir
mal deinen gesinnungsablauf ab [Applaus]